good morning EG it's Sunday we're doing
a week of Brotherhood 2.0 style daily
Vlogs as a punishment I want to talk
today about tax policy because that's a
good way to get views on YouTube but it
is the best example I can think of to
explore how far political rhetoric has
diverged from actual policy now bear in
mind that I'm not an expert I'm a guy
sitting in his basement wearing a suit
jacket a button-down shirt and boxers
but okay let's start with ordinary
income which is usually money that you
make at a job but it can be lots of
other things at any rate ordinary income
right now over
$388,000 is taxed at 35% President
Obama's deficit reduction plan would cut
taxes for most families but income over
$388,000 would be taxed at 39% instead
of 35 whereas Governor Romney's tax plan
would cut that top marginal tax rate to
about 28% now this means nothing for the
vast majority of us but if you're
married and you have one kid and make
$500,000 a year congratulations that's
fantastic under the Obama plan you'll
pay about $5,000 more than you currently
do Under the Romney plan you'll pay
about
$36,000 less than you currently do now
heck that's a significant difference but
look at it this way Obama's tax plan
would take tax rates to where they were
in the 1990s and Romney's tax plan would
set tax rates about where they were in
the late 1980s so like when political
pundits scream at each other on TV it's
basically one side saying this kind of
radical socialism hasn't been seen in
the United States for 12 entire years
and the other side you're like your
handouts to the Filthy Rich are entirely
unprecedented in all of American History
provided that American history began in
1991 so the differences are significant
but is one side communist and the other
side fascist no then you have capital
gain so the foundational idea of
industrial capitalism is that sometimes
you have to make large upfront
Investments to grow the economy you need
to buy an oven to start your pizza
business or a screen printer to start
your t-shirt business or some servers to
start your online video Enterprise if
your investment works out you make a lot
of money if it fails you lose everything
now these investors who are willing to
take risks are super useful to the
economy like Hank if you hadn't made a
large upfront investment in VidCon
VidCon never would have existed and that
would suck because one it's super fun
and two it has created jobs and the same
thing is true except on a much larger
scale with like YouTube so let's say
that you start YouTube and then you sell
it to Google the money that you make
from that sale is called capital gains
and it is taxed currently at 15% much
lower than the ordinary income tax rate
a similar thing is happening albeit in a
very extended way when you buy stock in
a company and then the value of that
company grows and you sell the stock
that's also capital gains so Hank the
idea here is that if we tax capital
gains at a lower rate it will encourage
entrepreneurship and investment it'll
encourage people who are working at
PayPal make an ordinary income to think
hm I should start YouTube and make me
some capital gains now Hank whether
people actually start businesses in the
hopes of being taxed at a slightly low
lower rate is an open question some
economists think this fuels growth
others don't but regardless as you can
see here from this game of snake I mean
graph the capital gains STX is at its
lowest point since 1972 President Obama
argues that we should raise that rate
back up to 20% where it was between 1997
and 2002 Governor Romney wants to keep
that 15% rate but completely eliminate
all tax on capital gains under
$250,000 he importantly that would also
mean that people who make like a billion
dollars in capital gains a year would
still pay no taxes at all on their first
$250,000 of capital gains income so Han
I think that's a bad idea and I think
President Obama's plan is better but I
might be wrong I've been wrong before
the truth is these are somewhat
different tax plans but neither of them
is radical and heck when we start to
imagine those who disagree with us as
crazy or evil or traitorous it becomes
difficult to compromise with them and
difficult to listen to them at times it
can be even difficult to stay friends
with them and hurdling insults instead
of having conversations about policy
leads to a social order where no one can
talk without screaming and that more
than either candidate's tax plan is
dangerous hey think I'll see you
tomorrow it's been a while since I said
that